It seems like everyone online is hyping
up Google V3 right now. But the truth is
that almost everyone I've seen using it
is doing it completely wrong. They're
wasting credits, getting mediocre
results, and leaving insane potential on
the table. That's why I've spent the
past month pushing V3 way past what most
people think is possible. And along the
way, I discovered the best way to use it
without wasting credits while still
unlocking its full video potential. So,
if you've been frustrated that your
videos never look like the ones you see
online, or a VO3 just feels too
expensive because your credits vanish
too fast, today I'm going to show you
the exact blueprint I used to go from
burning hundreds of credits to
generating insanely highquality results
in minutes. Now, the tool I'm going to
be using to access Google V3 is called
Open Art. Although it is a bit more
expensive to use VO through Open Art, it
adds so much extra functionality to your
AI workflow that at this point it makes
up for it. So once you sign up to open
art, you'll get met with this homepage
window. And to access Google V3, you
need to click on the left side here
where it says video. That takes you now
to the AI video workflow. Then in the
top left, you want to select text, which
is for text to video generation. And in
the select model field, as you can see
right now, there are tons of models that
Open Art offers. But what we want to do
is select Google V3 as our model. Now,
this allows us to enter our prompt. And
this brings me to one of the most
important part that you need to
understand in order to use V3 in the
most efficient way and that is how to
correctly prompt in V3. So Google V3 is
a very sophisticated model which means
that normal prompts the kind you might
type into chat GPT where you just
quickly ask for something will not give
you good results. To really understand
how much depth you can and honestly
should be adding into your prompts, let
me walk you through what I call the 10
components that you should almost always
include. So, whenever you start off your
prompt, you generally want to start with
a scene. That could be something like a
weathered sea captain delivers a line on
deck as the sun sets or it could be an
instruction for something like a man on
the street interview or a POV shot.
Next, you should follow with the
subject. So, who is the actual person?
What do they look like? For example, a
sea captain with a thick gray beard.
After that, you always want to include
background information. So, what is
actually happening in the background? Is
it a busy New York street out at sea? Or
maybe it's inside a dungeon? Then you
want to mention the action you want your
subject to take. For example, he gazes
towards the horizon or he jumps in front
of another person. After that, you want
to specify the style of the video. Is it
a horror cinematic shot which will add
more dark colors and intensity to the
scene or is it a comedy cinematic shot
which will do the opposite and actually
make the video lighter and more playful?
This is where you set the overall mood
of your video. Next comes the camera
settings, then the composition. And
after that, you should describe the
lighting and the mood. For example, you
could say golden hour with warm tones or
cold blue tones with heavy shadows. Now,
this is what really sets the atmosphere
of your video. Then you want to add the
audio. This could be a spoken line of
dialogue, the sound of ocean waves, or
even just background music. And at the
very end, you can choose to finish with
a specific color palette if you want to
go even deeper. So, for example, colder
tones that give you that sort of
interstellar movie look or warmer tones
that bring more warmth and vibrance to
your scene. And then don't forget
negative instructions. That's something
a lot of people overlook, but it's
really important to include because it
tells the model what not to generate.
That way, you don't get random or
unwanted things showing up in your
video. I know this seems like a lot, but
this is such an important step if you
want to make your workflow with V3 much
more efficient. And to make sure you
still get the benefits of writing very
detailed prompts without spending hours
doing it manually, I've made a short AI
template that you can use. You just
paste it into ChatGpt and in the bracket
section, you simply describe your idea.
So, I'm going to open a new ChatGpt
chat. paste it in and inside the bracket
I'll just write my simple idea. For
example, a street interview with a
chimp. That's a very vague idea. But
when I send it off to chat GPT, you can
see the AI expands it into a much
longer, much more specific prompt. All I
have to do is take this expanded prompt,
go back to Open Art, and paste it into
the prompt window. Now, what you can
also do is turn on the enhance feature.
This automatically enhances your prompt
even further. You don't always need this
when you've already written a very
detailed prompt, but it can be really
useful if you just want something quick
or if you're working with simpler AI
models. Then in the settings, you'll see
a few options. You can toggle the audio
on or off. You can select the
resolution. I usually go with the
highest resolution possible for the best
results. And then you'll see the mode
selector, which is actually a pretty
interesting option. Here you can choose
between fast mode and normal mode. What
fast mode really is is basically a
cheaper and a more cramped version of
the normal mode. So, you're still
getting a version of Google V3, but it's
stripped down a bit. It is still as
good, if not even slightly better in
terms of quality compared to other AI
video generators. But where it really
starts to look a little bland is in the
movements. They become slower, more
blunt, and just not as natural. And
honestly, I don't really recommend using
fast mode because if you're already
using Google V3 through Open Art, you're
just better off selecting another model
altogether, like clinging. So, for me
personally, I almost always stick with
normal mode. Now that we've set
everything up, let's go ahead and
generate a video and take a look at the
results.
>> So, what brings you to the city today?
>> Honestly, just wanted to see what all
the hype was about.
>> And how's it going so far?
>> Busy, loud, but I kind of like it.
>> And as you can see, it came out looking
very realistic considering it's a chimp
answering a human's questions. Now, the
only problem I have with this video is
the resolution. It's only in 1080p, and
that really makes the quality almost
unusable if you want to use it in a
higher production video or anywhere else
where you need a higher scale. But this
problem is totally solvable. Let me show
you how. With the video open, look at
the bottom right corner. Here you can
select the upscaling feature by clicking
on video upscale. That opens a new
window with your video already selected.
Now in the resolution menu, you just
pick the resolution you want it to
upscale to. I'm going with 4K here. And
not only that, but you can also choose
the FPS you want the video upscaled to.
I'm selecting the highest option here as
well. Then I hit enhance video. And
let's compare.
>> So, what brings you to the city today?
>> Honestly, just wanted to see what all
the hype was about
>> and how's it going. So far,
>> busy, loud, but I kind of like it.
>> And as you can see, looking at these two
shots side by side, the difference is
massive, especially if you're working on
a higher production project, the
upscaling really gives you the extra
clarity and detail you need. All right,
now let's take a look at image to video
with Google V3. So, to access image to
video, you just click at the top where
it says image and then select the
correct model. Here in the interface,
I'm going to drop in this image of a
samurai that I have right here. And now
we have the option to add our prompt.
For this, I'm going to use the same
template that I showed you earlier. The
only difference is that at the
beginning, I'll tell Chat GBT that it
should use this image as the starting
frame. So, I insert the image and then I
continue building the rest of the prompt
exactly the same way I would for text to
video. Now, generally, image to video
works very similar to text to video. But
one thing you need to keep in mind is
that you should always try to start with
the highest quality image possible.
Because since the AI is building the
video based on your image, the final
quality of your video will depend
heavily on the quality of the image you
upload. So if you're starting with a
lowquality image, the output will almost
always look a little worse than you
expect. That's why it's best to find
something highquality before you start.
Besides this, the settings are pretty
much the same. And here again, I don't
really recommend using fast mode. With
Google V3, it won't generate the video
significantly faster. And the only thing
you really get back is a worst-l looking
video that isn't even much cheaper than
normal mode. So, let's just go ahead and
generate the video.
And as you can see, it came out looking
very good. There's not really much I
could point out as a problem here. Maybe
the close-up looks a little bit weird,
but besides that, the video matches the
photo perfectly. It keeps the same style
of the image that I uploaded. And
overall, it just looks really good. So
now you know exactly how to stop wasting
credits and unlock the full power of
Google V3 and you can go ahead and start
creating insanely highquality videos
with it today. And with Open Art, you
get way more than just VO access. You
get all the extra features bundled into
one simple workflow, making it
ridiculously easy to create, manage, and
scale your videos. And what keeps me
coming back is how they're always first
to integrate the newest AI models.
Whenever a breakthrough model like V3 or
the latest version of Cling Drops, Open
Art usually has it available within
days. So, if you're ready to start
creating videos just like the ones I
show you today, click the link below and
sign up for Open Art.